لا كلمه بسيطه غير محببه بصراحه ما كان
بودنا نبدا فيها حلقه اليوم لكن لا
وفاجئني عادل انا قاعده بطلع عليه يعني
يلا يا عادل يلا لا الخبراء مشاهدينا
يوضحون ان هذه الكلمه مهمه جدا وان هناك
خيطا رفيعا فاصلا بين العطاء وارضاء
الاخرين وبين القيام بذلك على حساب
متطلباتك الشخصيه وهذا الفاصل هو كلمه لا
خبراء سلوكي يوضحون بان العطاء المفرط
يمكن ان يكون مؤشر واضح على التدني
الاحترام للذات بالتالي علينا ان نعرف
جيدا
فن ان نقول كلمه لا
مشاهدينا نشره موقع هاكسبيرت وضع ع يجب
علينا معرفتها لتجنب الوقوع في دوامه
ارضاء الاخرين على حساب انفسنا وراحتنا
الشخصيه كلها سنتابعها في هذا الشرح
التالي مع الزميل على تفضلي على
علاء وعطاء هو عطاء بلا حدود عطاء سرحان
شكرا عادل وراويه وهذه علامات تشير الى
انك ترضي الاخرين على حسابك اولها
الموافقه على اي طلبات للاخرين باستمرار
هذا قد يصل بك الى الشعور بالارهاق او
الاجهاد وايضا قد يجعلك فريسه سهله لمن
يدركون انك لا تستطيع قول لا وبالتالي هذه
علامه اخرى اي انك ستصبح محاصرا بهؤلاء
الذين
يستغلونك لحل مشاكلهم واحتياجاتهم وتحقيق
رغباتهم كذلك عندما تشعر بالاستياء بعد
مساعده الاخرين بدل الشعور بال لان هذه
حاله تشير لعدم التوازن بين الاخذ والعطاء
كذلك تجنب الصراع او الاستسلام والموافقه
مباشره على استغلال الاخر لك بسبب عدم
الرغبه في المواجهه فتفضيل التنازل عن
القيم والاولويات والاحتياجات بدلا من
المجادله هذه علامه اخرى وايضا محاوله
ارضاء الجميع
وعندما يساورك خوف من ان عدم تلبيه اي طلب
ربما يجعلك غير محبوب او مرفوض من
الاصدقاء
وننهي بعلامه مهمه وهي اهمال الاحتياجات
الشخصيه والشعور بانك تخشى ان ينظر اليك
على انك اناني على كل حال سالنا الناس في
الاردن كيف تقول لا لمن لا تود ان تخسر
وده او صداقته لنتابع
[موسيقى]
بحكيها بطريقه حلوه
من غير ما ازعل من غير ما اضايقه بجيب
اسلوب كتير حلو يعني بفهمه بس مش من غير
ما احكي له لا عشان انه ما يتحسس او يزعل
هو الموضوع اللي بده اياه
ممكن اشي يعني سهل يعني اقدر اخدمه فيه
السبب اول اشي انه ليش انا ما بدي هذا
الشيء وبحاول اضل بيني وبينه دائما حبل
الود موجود طبعا هذا اهم اشي
[موسيقى]
معنى لا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو مدربه
الحياه لين اللاز اهلا بك يا لين معنا
صباح الخير صباح الخير كيفك يا ليندا
الحمد لله لين قيل بانه حريه الانسان
تنتهي عندما تبدا حريه الاخرين ولكن هل
ايضا ساعدت تنده تنتهي عندما يكثر من
ارضاء الاخرين عن جد هلا اكيد لما نحن
نكون عم نرضي حالنا على حساب عم نرضي
الاشخاص اللي حوالينا على حساب حالنا
واحتياجاتنا وحتى ايامنا امرار وما بيدئنا
بالحياه ممكن كتير انا تاثر على سعادتنا
طبعا
بس هي تاثر ايضا على احترام الذات بتاثر
على احترام الذات ليش لانه نحن اليوم
بالمجتمع بينا
على هي مرتبطه بقديش نحن بنقدم للاشخاص
اللي حوالينا وبنفس الوقت بنستصعب انه
نقول لا للاشخاص لانه بالنسبه لالنا بيهدد
قيمتنا لحالنا بس بنفس الوقت ما بنفكر
فيها بطريقه ثانيه هي الحياه كلها عباره
عن توازن يعني اخذوا عطاء اخذوا عطاء وبده
يكون في توازن بالاخذ والعطاء بكثير اوقات
انا اذا بدي لبي اشخاص اللي حوالي وانا
كبيتي تكون فاضيه لمحل ما بقدر لا البس
الشخص اللي حواليه ولا حتى لبي حالي خليني
اعترف بس انتو انا قبل شوي لما قلت لك لا
شعرت بانه كلمه الله كلمه جميله صحيح هي
كلمه لا بتساعدك انك تحط حدود مع الاشخاص
اللي حواليك بس الاشخاص بتخافي
عندي مش في ما يتعلق
لانه بالنسبه لالها اول شيء يمكن تخاف
تخسر الشخص من قبيله مع انه بنفس الوقت ما
بنفكر انه مثل ما الشخص هو يعني قرر انه
يسالنا او يطلب منك طلب اخذ بعين الاعتبار
العلاقه يلي موجوده بيناتنا اعطى لحاله
الحق انه يسال هذا السؤال انا كمان اليوم
المتلقي عند الحق كمان بقديش علاقتنا هي
قويه ومتينه اني انا لبى الطلب او ما لب
الطلب بحسب قديش انا قادره اعطي او مش
قادره اعطي وبدون ما تتاثر علاقتنا طبعا
احنا في الثقافه العربيه بالفعل زي ما كنا
عم نحكي انا وعادل قبل شوي كثير صعب تقول
لا يعتبر كانه انت انسان مش خدوم مش كريم
مش متعاون اناني بالضبط يعني كيف ممكن انه
نوصل لمرحله خصوصا بثقافه بخصوصيه ثقافتنا
العربيه نقدر نقول لا بدون ما نخسر من نحب
طبعا هلا اول شيء بدنا نتوقع انه الشخص
يلي بحبنا هو ما بحبنا على شيء نحن كل شيء
تفسير ليش انا عم اقول لا هو مهم لانه
الاسلوب نحن بحاجه له يوم انت كنت عم
تقولي انه هو فن فن ليش لانه الاسلوب هو
اهم من كلمه لا كيف الطريقه كيف نقول لا
اهم من الكاميرا طبعا لا لا
هيك لا ممكن تكون بطريقه كتير اذا الشخص
تفضل صحيح هذه الطريقه كتير هيك جذبه
وقويه قصدي مش مش خاطئه بس اليوم اذا
الشخص المقابيلك بيعني لك وانت بتعني له
بدك تاخذ بعين الاعتبار انه هو يمكن طيب
يعني اجامل على لا اجامل على حساب نفسي
باني انا الطف كلمه لا حتى يقتنع الطرف
اللي امامي بانه انا تعبان ولا استطيع ان
اعطيه كلمه مثلا اليوم اذا انت
عم بتتنا علاقه صداقه قويه متينه يكون
جوابي لا
اوكي لا او اذا بقول لك مثلا لا والله
كتير تعبانه قالت لي يا ريت بقدر اساعدك
بس عن جد انا كتير تعبانه يعني كله
بالاسلوب هذا اسلوب
يعني تعال على نفسك لا بس لا يعني
هي فعلا تعبانه طب احنا يعني قبل ما ننهي
حبيت بس اعرف هل في مرحله الاكثار من كلمه
لا بتصير بالفعل تنقلب ضد الانسان ويصبح
اناني وكل الامور لعددناه طبعا هون بنرجع
للكلمه الاساسيه باي شيء بالحياه اللي هو
التوازن لا بدي اعطي كثير ولا بدي كمان
اخذ كثير ولا كمان ما اعطي ابدا لانه هذا
الشيء بورجي كثير عن شخصيتي بوجه عن قديش
انا بقدر اقدم للاشخاص اللي حوالي عن اني
انا استغلالي ولا ماني استغلالي بيعطي
كتير كتير انا ساستمع الى كلام مدربه
الحياه لينا وراح اقول لا اي حد وسام لا
تبالغ وسام فيروز لا
والله كلكم لا حتى جمال لا يلا شكرا وليس
لا
انا للنومة يسال
نا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات